geralt of rivia's bad luck continues it
seems
a little over a month after production
on the netflix series the witcher
resumed
season two cast member to rasmussen who
was set to play the witcher s goal has
dropped out of the show due to a covet
19 related scheduling conflict the actor
announced the news on instagram
writing sadly due to the rescheduling
because of covet 19 i will not be
portraying eskel in the witcher
it's heartbreaking of course but i
mostly feel happy and grateful for the
days i got to spend on set earlier this
year everyone was extremely engaged and
passionate about the project and it was
a truly inspiring experience
rasmussen went on to thank everyone for
supporting him and wished the cast and
crew of the witcher good luck
concluding i'm sure season two will be
absolutely amazing and
now i get to watch it as a fanboy
instead of a witcher
losing rasmussen is a blow for season
two considering eskel's importance in
the witcher book series by andre
sapkowski
on which the netflix show is based in
the books as well as in the witcher
video games eskel is a close friend to
geralt of rivia the lead character
played by henry cavill
on the tv series rasmussen's exit is yet
another roadblock in the witcher season
2's journey to our screens production on
the season was halted in march due to
covet 19 and at the time a spokesperson
for netflix issued a statement to
deadline
optimistically suggesting that
production would resume in early april
instead another season two newcomer game
of thrones favorite christopher hibiew
revealed that he had tested positive for
covet 19 shortly after production was
halted for cnn
thankfully the witcher cast and crew are
safely back to work but rasmussen's exit
creates a new hurdle for the series who
will take on the pivotal role now
and what will a potential recast mean
for season 2's release date
escull isn't the only new witcher on the
block in the upcoming season
the show also announced casting for
lambert to be played by paul boulian
cohen played by yasin ator
and elder witch vesemir played by kim
bodnia
in blood evalves the first full-length
witcher novel all four witchers joined
geralt orivia in training siri
at caremorin the home base for the
witchers the casting of geralt's pals
suggests that blood of elves will be the
inspiration for season two and it's hard
to imagine the storyline working without
eskel by geralt's side
as expected netflix has been cagey about
releasing plot details for the new
season
however the casting announcements offer
a clear idea of what's next for geralt
and his child of surprise
siri now that the two have finally found
each other the witcher will be helping
her harness and control her powers with
assistance from the men he himself
trained with as a young man
of those men eskel has the strongest
connection to the perpetually grumpy
geralt on season 1 the white wolf is
seen as a friendless loner
aside from his faithful bard yaskir
played by joey beatty
introducing eskel to the story means
delving into geralt's past
and the painful childhood that he shared
with his fellow witchers
having a character on the show who knows
geralt so intimately should go a long
way in fleshing out his backstory and
explaining how he became the cynical
bath-loving hero fans know and love so
it seems very
unlikely that the show will just cut
escal entirely but covet 19 restrictions
will no doubt complicate the process of
replacing rasmussen
not only will a potential replacement
have to quarantine for two weeks before
joining the cast and cruise filming
bubble but the actor selected will
likely also need to be a resident of the
uk
where the show is filmed the series has
an international cast with actors
hailing from all around the world but
with travel restrictions still in place
for some countries having a local actor
step into the role would surely expedite
the process
no matter who is ultimately cast
rasmussen's exit will almost
certainly lead to another delay in
completing season 2.
with that in mind fans should prepare
themselves for the possibility that the
witcher season 2 won't actually land on
netflix until late 2021
at the earliest check out one of our
newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one